when we are in a comfort zone we're not
learning new things and it's not that
we're stagnating but we're not expanding
once we push ourselves into the Learning
Zone we're meeting new challenges but
then as we overcome these and meet the
new stimulus and absorb it all we grow
we learn and that's the Learning Zone
some people even talk about the Panic
Zone where we're in a Zone where things
are too difficult for us and we can't
cope and then it's Panic so obviously in
learning a language we want to push
ourselves outside of our comfort zone
however I have always found as a
strategy
that it's very important to find as many
ways as possible to take some level of
comfort some of your comfort zone into
the Learning Zone